[Applause]
[Music]
he is a singer-songwriter who approaches
the craft as a storyteller and rebels in
the complexities of the human experience
and he's about to drop his highly
anticipated album
unbreakable i got my copy now welcome
chadwick johnson thank you mercedes it's
great to be so excited i'm looking at
the track list you've got 13 tracks and
a bonus track on this puppy how was the
experience on making this what fourth
album of yours it's the fourth album
yeah wow yeah it was super exciting you
know i recorded a lot of it in nashville
and some of it here in las vegas and
some of it in los angeles so it's been
over the last two years it's just been
really exciting tell me about the story
of unbreakable
where does this come from yeah you know
we've all been living through it's no
secret we've been living through a time
when we needed to feel some resilience
and we need i think most of us are so
resilient and we feel unbreakable and
that's really where i was when i was
writing that song and that's what it's
about it's about
you know connecting to that part of
yourself that feels strong and like you
can come back from adversity your your
songs are so relatable and yeah you're
right so many people went through that
and and i think a lot of people are just
now feeling like they could come back
you doing this for as long as you have
when did you know
like
my voice is pretty good
maybe i should uh make a career out of
this when did you figure that out you
know i think i i loved singing from a
little little boy
and you know then you know you get those
first times you perform you get bit by
the bug and and you know it's it's just
live music and music in general is such
a way to connect with people and you
know that's the most important part of
life is who you connect with on this
journey and so music just allowed me to
make those connections in such a
beautiful positive way what was the song
that you would sing i heard you do uh a
rendition of a an 80s song that josh
blew me away but
crowded house the one cover we you know
the the album is all original music
except one cover and it's the the
crowded house song from 1986 don't dream
it's over oh my gosh you know it's a
timeless song and i tried to put my spin
on it and and just it was it was wild to
me when i was listening to it and
recording it how
um
the lyrics are still so relevant today
it really is your voice is incredible
now if people want to see you you're
going to be performing yeah tell us
where you're going to be here in town
you know i i
kick off in las vegas the first of four
album release shows so that'll be this
friday the 16th at the space
i love that venue awesome venue at eight
o'clock so that's this friday and then
we go on to palm springs next week and
los angeles and then new york city we
wrap up the release shows so it's it's
an exciting few weeks now if people want
to go see the show they just have to go
to the website the spaces yep yep i
think you all have the link but if not
you can go to my website
chadwickjohnson.com and all the show
links are right there do that get the
album his album release again september
16th
as well as his uh show over at the space
show time is 8 p.m tickets more info
available at the space lv dot com thank
you so much
rocky over to you